Bitte schön.
Okay. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Gümüş. Ich bin die Dienstabende Arstin und werde jetzt das Aufnahmegeschichte mit Ihnen durchführen.
Als Erste werde ich Ihnen ein paar generelle Fragen zur Stelle Ihrer Person stellen. Bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Michael Horst Kotte.
Michael Horst?
Horst Kotte.
Kotte.
Könnte Sie bitte Ihren Form nachnamen, büchde birn?
Ja, Michael schreibt sich M-I-C-H-A-E-L.
Michael und Horst Kotte.
O-R-S-T-K-O-T-T-E. Horst Kotte.
Horst Kotte. Herr Hauskotte?
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
62.
Ja.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 4. März 1962.
4. März 1962.
Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
Ja.
Wie viel liegen Sie seit Herr Hauskotte?
93 kg.
93 kg?
Ja.
Was führt Sie zu Herr Hauskotte?
Ja, ich habe ungefähr seit 3 Wochen
habe ich Schmerzen im Bereich der linken Hüfte
und des linken Oberschenkels.
Aber jetzt seit 2 Tagen haben die Schmerzen sehr stark zugenommen.
Sodass ich gar nicht mehr richtig gehen kann
und auch nicht gut stehen kann.
Ja, das ist jetzt sehr stark geworden.
Seit 3 Wochen sind die linken Hüfte und den Oberschenkels.
Ja.
Okay.
Wie sind die Beschwerden aufgetreten?
Plötzlich oder langsam?
Langsam.
Langsam? Okay.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ja.
Die sind mehr so dumpf und bohrend.
Dumpf und bohrend?
Ja.
Sind die Beschwerden dauerhafter
oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Nein, sie sind in den letzten Tagen dauernd.
Im Anfang war es noch,
im Anfang vor 3 Wochen war es noch etwas weniger,
im Anfang war es mal da, mal nicht da.
Aber jetzt seit einigen Tagen sind Sie immer da.
Einigen Tagen und jetzt immer da.
Ja.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10,
wenn ein sehr leicht und sehr stark ist?
Ich will sagen zwischen 5 und 7.
Ja.
Okay.
Wie haben sich die Beschwerden-Mitallzeit verändert?
Ja, in den letzten 2 Tagen sind Sie ganz stark geworden.
Vorher waren vielleicht 5, aber jetzt sind Sie fast immer 7.
Und es tut weh im Liegen, es tut weh im Sitzen besonders stark,
wenn ich versuche, mich etwas zu bewegen.
Ja, das ist ein sehr starker Punkt.
Es tut weh im Sitzen besonders stark,
wenn ich versuche, mich etwas zu bewegen oder zu gehen
oder zu stehen, dann wird es besonders schlimm.
Ich konnte in den letzten 2 Tagen auch nicht arbeiten.
Okay.
Schmerzen, Sie trauen sich irgendwo hin?
Ja, Sie gehen mehr so dann auch Richtung Knie,
ins linke Knie, aber hauptsächlich sind Sie mehr
in der Hüfte und im oberen Oberschenkel.
Seit 3 Wochen linken und hüfte schmerzen,
aber australen in die Knie.
In das linke Knie, ja?
Linke Knie, okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für die Schmerzen?
Ja, also jetzt wenn ich versuche, mich hinzustellen
oder zu gehen, dann wird das schlimmer.
Das kann ich nicht mehr.
Wenn ich versuche, mich hinzustellen oder zu gehen,
dann werden die Schmerzen schlimmer.
Das kann ich gar nicht, weil es so weh tut.
Okay.
Hatten Sie so etwas früher schon einmal?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Erst einmal?
Ja.
Haben Sie schon einmal?
Nein, ich habe es schon einmal.
Haben Sie bemerkt geschwollene Beine?
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass das Bein geschwollene ist.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt Rotung, Wärmegefühl im Beine?
Nein, nicht bemerkt.
Teufelsgefühl?
Nein, kein Teufelsgefühl.
Okay.
Leiden Sie Krippel in Beine?
Kribbeln?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Kein Kribbeln.
Okay.
Haben Sie apetitlosigkeit?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, haben Sie leise Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Ja, Schlafstörungen.
Eigentlich nicht, ich muss nachts in der Regel zweimal auf Toilette und Wasser lassen,
aber ich kann danach wieder einschlafen.
Wie oft müssen Sie gehen auf Toilette?
Zweimal, manchmal sogar dreimal.
Zweimal bis dreimal nachts.
Okay.
Haben Sie andere Probleme beim Wasser lassen?
Urinfarkt, Veränderung?
Ja, ich habe, der Hahnstrahl ist nicht mehr so stark und kräftig,
das hängt, glaube ich, mit meiner Operation zusammen.
Welche Prostation?
Ich bin vor drei Jahren an der Prostata operiert worden wegen Prostatacrebs.
Prostatacrebs, Prostata Antfarno?
Ja, die Prostata ist entfernt worden und anschließend wurde es noch bestrahlt.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Husten?
Husten habe ich, ja, ich habe, glaube ich, einen chronischen Husten.
Ich musste auch Medikamente nehmen, das hängt, glaube ich, mit meinem Rauchen zusammen.
Welche Medikamente einnehmen?
Das eine ist Buddisonit, Buddisonit-Spray,
nämlich zweimal am Tag.
Zweimal?
Zweimal und einmal Salbutamol-Spray, das nehme ich mehr so bei Bedarf.
Wenn es gerade im Winter und Herbst, dann wird das schlimmer, schlechter mit der Bronchitis.
Dann muss ich auch Salbutamol-Spray nehmen.
Salbutamol, gegen, welchen gegen, Krankenheit?
Ja, wegen der Bronchitis auch.
Mit der Luftnot, dann bekomme ich manchmal schlecht Luft und habe viel Schleim und viel Auswurf.
Und deswegen muss ich das nehmen.
Okay.
Welche Dosierung bist denn Sie?
Salbutamol-Spray, zweimal am Tag, aber das hängt davon ab, wie es mir geht.
Manchmal, am manchen Tagen nehme ich gar nichts.
Buddisonit nehme ich zweimal am Tag, regelmäßig.
Buddis.
Wie viel Milligramm Buddisonit?
Das weiß ich nicht, was da für Milligramm draufsteht.
Okay. Haben Sie viel wahr?
Nein.
Nein. Nachtschweiß oder Schüttelfrost?
Nachtschweiß in letzter Zeit habe ich schon häufiger Mal, aber kein Schüttelfrost.
Okay. Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Nein.
Nein. Leiden Sie Sortbrennen und Ausdosen?
Okay.
Haben Sie, vor Erkrankung, Prostatkrebs und...
3 Jahren, wie gesagt, Prostatkrebs.
Und da bin ich immer in Kontrolle beim Urologen.
Ja.
Vor fünf Wochen war ich dort wieder zur Kontrolle, auch Blutwerte.
Und da war dieser PSA-Wert erhöht.
Da hat der Urologe gesagt, ich soll jetzt in 2 Wochen oder 10 Tagen wiederkommen,
um das zu kontrollieren.
Der war etwas erhöht.
Und da hat er gesagt, das muss kontrolliert werden.
Okay.
Und sonst habe ich eben eine chronische Bronchitis seit ungefähr 4 Jahren,
deswegen nehme ich die Medikamente.
Da bin ich auch beim Lungenfacharzt in Kontrolle.
Und ich habe hohen Blutdruck seit ungefähr 6 Jahren,
habe ich hohen Blutdruck?
Ja.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente gegen Blutdruck?
Ja, da nehme ich zwei verschiedene Medikamente.
Das eine Medikamente heißt Bisoprolol.
Da nehme ich zwei Tabletten pro Tag,
eine morgens und eine abends.
Welche Dosieren, bisoprolol?
Da steht 5, 5-Hinter.
5 Milligramm.
Ja.
Okay.
Dann nehme ich noch, das ist jetzt umgestellt worden,
weil ich das eine Mittel nicht vertrug,
da habe ich noch mehr Husten bekommen.
Ich nehme jetzt Kandisartan.
Ja.
8 steht dahinter, da nehme ich auch zwei Tabletten,
eine morgens und eine abends.
Orgens und abends.
Welche Dosieren, Kandisartan?
Ja, 8 Milligramm.
8 Milligramm.
Okay.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert,
außer Prostat und Fernum?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich schon mal am Blindam operiert.
Und am Leistenbruch.
Das war, Blindam war so mit 10 Jahren glaube ich,
Leistenbruch war, da war ich ein bisschen älter.
13, 14.
Welche Seite Leistenbruch?
Rechte Seite.
Rechte.
Wann war das?
Ja, da war ich glaube ich 13 oder 14.
Vor 13.
Als ich 13 Jahre alt war.
Okay.
Ich wurde am Leistenbruch operiert.
Und ja, und so die Prostatoperation.
Okay.
Haben Sie allergin etwas gegen?
Allergien.
Ja, ich habe es schon mal gemacht.
Haben Sie allergin etwas gegen?
Allergien habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche ziemlich viel.
Schon lange, 40 Jahre lang.
Rauch ich eine Schachtel.
Und ich habe aber aufgehört vor einem Jahr.
Weil alle mir gesagt haben,
ich muss mit dem Rauchen aufhören.
Das wird sonst immer schlechter mit meiner Bronchitis.
Und vor einem Jahr habe ich aufgehört.
Das habe ich geschafft.
Und ich habe euch 40 Jahre lang geraucht.
Das ist gut zu entscheiden.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Herr Hausgold?
Ja, ich trinke so abends eine Flasche Bier.
Abends eine Flasche Bier.
Okay.
Drogen Sie?
Nehmen Sie die Drogen?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Und wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder.
Die sind 33 Jahre alt und 35 Jahre alt.
Und die Jüngere, die 33-Jährige,
die hat eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse.
Und die haben eine Unterfunktion der Schilddrüse.
Unterfunktion.
Das nimmt sie aber schon einige Jahre Medikamente.
Ein Medikament.
Und darunter ist die Schilddrüse wieder kleiner geworden.
Okay.
Wissen Sie, wer ist der Medikament?
Nein, das weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Interfamilien und Amnesen kommen via.
Und wie ist Ihre Eltern?
Die Eltern leben in der Mutter.
Die Mutter ist 86 Jahre alt.
Die hat schweres Gelenkräumer.
So entzündliches Gelenkräumer.
Und sie hat auch eine starke Herzmuskel-Schwäche.
Sodass sie kaum mehr geht.
Sie geht an einem Rollator.
Aber sie kann sich schlecht mehr bewegen.
Das ist zu anstrengend.
Der Vater ist im Alter von 74 Jahren an Prostatakrebs verstorben.
Können Sie wiederholen bitte?
Der Vater war 74 Jahre alt.
Als er an Prostatakrebs verstorben ist.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schwester?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Er ist 60 Jahre alt.
Und der hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Ich kontrolliere meine Notiere.
Sind Sie im Vorstand im Impfpass?
Ich glaube schon.
Der Hausarzt überprüft regelmäßig den Impfpass.
Er sagt, ich brauche im Arm die keine Impfungen.
Ich bekomme einmal einen Impfpass.
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Er sagt, ich brauche keine Impfungen.
Ich bekomme einmal im Jahr im Herbst eine Grippe-Impfung.
Ich habe von Covid-Impfungen 4 bekommen.
Im Augenblick brauche ich nichts.
Es ist nichts Notwendig.
Okay.
Ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügeln?
Was kann ich denn haben?
Ich habe keine Sorgen.
Ich verstehe Ihre Schmerzen.
Ich werde körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde auf die Aufnahme.
Ja, eine wichtige Frage. Nein, ich kann mich an einen Unfall nicht erinnern. Ich bin zwar im Winter einmal, aber das war schon im Winter, beim Schneeräumen ausgerutscht und auf die Seite gefallen.
Das hat etwas geschmerzt, aber es ist dann besser geworden. Aber einen direkten Unfall, so habe ich nicht gehabt.
Morgensteifigkeit.
Was meinen Sie darunter? Morgensteifigkeit.
Zu der Erwirkung ist besonders schwierig, wenn Sie aufstehen.
Nein, so habe ich das nicht bemerkt. Aber ich habe ja seit drei Wochen alles nicht mehr so richtig in Ordnung, aber morgensteifigkeit nicht.
Zwei Fragen hätte ich noch, wenn sonst niemand mehr Fragen hätte. Haben Sie gegen die Schmerzmittel eingenehm?
Ja, Schmerzmittel.
Ja, ich habe in den letzten Tagen, als das so stark wurde, einmal von meiner Frau IWU-Profen bekommen.
Das war 400. IWU-Profen 400. Da habe ich zwei genommen, aber das hat nicht so viel geholfen.
Dann habe ich auch noch einmal Paracetamol genommen gestern, aber das hat vielleicht etwas geholfen, aber nicht zufriedenstellend.
Im Winter haben Sie Kontrollierungen, irgendwelche Arzt oder eine Diagnose wurde damals gestattet?
Im Winter, als ich ausgerutscht war, das war nicht so schlimm, ich konnte auch arbeiten.
Ich möchte auch noch meinen Beruf nennen. Ich wurde noch nicht nach dem Beruf gefragt.
Ich bin Postbote. Also ich trage Briefe aus in die Häuser.
Aber Luftnot haben Sie?
Nein, Luftnot habe ich nicht, aber oft Husten wegen meiner chronischen Bronchitis.
Wann hätten Sie gegen Prostatekrebs kontrollieren?
Jetzt sollte das Blut wieder neu kontrolliert werden.
Der Blutwert wollte sehen, ob der Wert erhöht ist oder sich verändert hat.
Vor fünf Wochen hatte ich eine Kontrolle und er hat erhöht.
Der Urloge hat gesagt, das müssen wir in einigen Wochen kontrollieren.
Deshalb soll das jetzt in zehn Tagen passieren.
Könnten Sie auf dem Bett schlucken und Beine auftreten?
Ja, aber es geht nicht gut. Seit zwei Tagen geht das nicht gut.
Vorher konnte ich noch auftreten und auch gehen, etwas eingeschränkt.
Aber jetzt seit zwei Tagen kann ich gar nicht mehr richtig auftreten.
Das ist zu schmerzhaft.
Können wir als Hessische Klang anfangen?
Ja.
Ich bin jetzt der Oberarzt.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt. Mein Name ist Gümüş.
Heute möchte ich Ihnen gerne die Patienten vorstellen.
Meine Patientin ist Michael Harzkotte.
Er ist 62 Jahre alt, 1 Meter, 4 und 80 groß und 3 und 9 Kilogramm schwer.
Der Patient stellt sich bei uns wegen seit drei Wochen
in der
Auf einer Skala anfangen fünf, aber später sieben von zehn.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam begonnen und dumm bohren.
Die Schmerzen sind immer da, progressiv und persistierend.
Wenn er hin zu liegen und hin zu stehen, sind Schmerzen stark.
Er hat nicht ein Unfallerreignis.
Er hat keine Unfall.
Er hat zwei bis drei Mal nachts.
Er hat nachschweiß seit einigen Tagen.
Er hat vegan prostatocarpitis, prostatectomy, für drei Jahre.
Er besucht regelmäßige Örologien.
Er hat seit sechs Jahren.
Er hat eine Abkürzung von COPD.
Ich versuche einmal zu wiederholen, was Sie mir gesagt haben.
Er hat ein 62-jähriger Patient mit eine Erkrankung von 1,84 m groß und 93 kg schwer.
Er hat eine Schmerzschmerz, die in der Linke hüftet und oberschenkelt.
Er hat Schmerzen seit drei Wochen in dieser Region, die aber nicht so stark waren.
Die Schmerzintensität wird zwischen 5 und 7 angegeben.
Er hat nicht stattgefunden.
Er hat gewicht gehalten oder gibt es Gewichtsveränderungen?
Es besteht eine Nüktorie von zwei bis drei Mal.
Er hat regelmäßigen Stuhlgang.
Vor drei Jahren wurde eine Vorsorge, die unaufwändig war.
Der Patient hat gesagt, Strahlentherapie.
Er hat eine Operation, eine Prostatektomie und eine Radiation erfolgen.
Der Patient steht in regelmäßiger Kontrolle beim Urologen.
Er hat vor fünf Wochen einen erhöhten PSA-Wert.
Dieser PSA-Wert soll kontrolliert werden.
Er hat eine PSA-Wertkontrolle stattfinden.
Er hat noch andere chronische Erkrankungen.
Sie haben eine COPD und eine arterielle Hypertonie.
Er nimmt Buddhistonid zweimal und Beibedarf, Salbutamol gegen COPD.
Er nimmt ein Sofrolor, morgens und abends fünf Milligramm.
Er nimmt Kandisartan, abends und morgens acht Milligramm.
Er nimmt nicht gegen den Husten, sondern er hat gesagt, dass Medikament umgestellt wurde.
Vorher hat der Patient Rami Bril bekommen.
Rami Bril macht leider viel häufiger Husten als Kandisartan.
Das wurde umgestellt, danach wurde der Husten etwas besser.
Er hat sich eine chronische Brontitis.
Er hat sich eine Erkrankung von 8-Initial-Allergischen.
Er hat oft eine Nebenwirkung von ACE-Hemmern, der Reizhusten.
Rami Bril macht das häufiger als Satane.
Er folgt die Umstellung auf ein Satan.
Er nimmt Unverzweglichkeit oder Allergische?
Er ist in Deutschland eher von Unverträglichkeit.
Er wird als Kind eine Pandectomy.
Er wird in der Kindheit eine Ependectomy erfolgt.
Er ist in Deutschland eher von Unverträglichkeit.
Er ist nicht Raucherin vor einem Jahr.
Aber früher hat sich ein Schachterl-Package geraucht.
Das entspricht sich für sich.
Sie können sagen, es bestand bis vor einem Jahr ein Nikotin ab Usus über 40 Packages.
Er ist ein Flöscherbier.
Er ist verheiratet und lebt mit seiner Frau.
Er hat zwei Kinder.
Er hat eine Tochter.
Er hat eine Schilddrüsen-Vergrösserung mit Unterfunktion.
Er ist eine Stromer.
Er ist ein Sturmer.
Er lebt 86 Jahre alt.
Er hat eine Herzmuskelschwäche.
Er ist eine Herzmuskelschwäche.
Er ist ein Schwester.
Er hat Arterialipartone.
Er ist eine Ostseerephilia.
Er ist ein Schleichender Beginn.